citizens of the reject Nation we are
back to be invaded with episode 4 today
John how's it going I am uh
shape-shifting into all forms of
excitement it's getting better jokoy how
are you I hope the invasion Isn't So
secret so people start watching the show
nice I like to hear it ladies and
Gentlemen please go ahead and invade
that like button also if you are
planning on going to Comic-Con real
rejects us three are going to be having
a panel Saturday July 22nd one o'clock
P.M Link in the description box for more
details can't wait to see what more of
that Fury goodness is up to that dog
with his bird's eye view what am I
everyone leave the video my feathered
rejects today I've got a tail waggingly
good Scoop for you let's talk about our
sponsor bird dogs I'm wearing them
comfortable pants right now but also
they have their shorts that'll have you
looking fetching these shorts are no
bird brainers my friends let me show you
they're designed to fit Slimmer through
the thigh and the leg giving you a truly
possum sculpted look they do everything
Lululemon does but with an extra wag in
their tail so say goodbye to those rough
cotton shorts bird dogs fix that Mudder
by creating their Cloud knit fabric I
mean come on it looks as sharp as khaki
but stretches like a dog chasing its
tail you're just gonna waste them or fit
without being you know leash stricted
got these puns going people here's the
cherry on top or should I say the bird
on the wire when you order from bird
dogs.com using my special code rejects
you'll fetch a free Yeti style tumbler
it's the perfect companion for hydrating
on your adventures
ah Grandpa's medicine so don't sit on
the perch my pals hurry over to
birddogs.com rejects to unleash the
possum power of these shorts and snag
your free Yeti style tumblers trust me
once you experience the comfort and
style you'll be barking about bird dogs
to all your buddies they really are
comfortable and a lot of people want to
know what are some of the best ways to
support the channel one of the best ways
to get yourself some bird dogs by
getting your tail wagon head to
birddogs.com rejects now
[Music]
ourselves
that's extremists I don't know if any of
the comments pointed it out last episode
I thought it was just common knowledge
among us all
away she's gonna set up right now
charity super it's like there's no way
they're killing him regenerative power
there it is that's extremist people
everybody knows Iron Man 3. Holdridge
Killian
what's funny is I didn't put together
his hand healing and her just doing the
same thing
[Music]
who would have thought that she's still
alive the thing that happened earlier in
the episode might also apply to her
skills I love when they just take that
big piece of stakes and just immediately
solve it as the opening button
it's a lot of filling in the gaps in
this show they do a good job jumping
around the timeline but not timelines as
I was watching all the news coverage of
those guys strangest thing someone I
know had something to do with getting
them all together
and what if it was someone you know half
of his face is de-aged
that looks so good he understands that
the weaker worth
goddamn right good book
actually it's a conversation
between two people
that will very much reflect our own
and did you get what you wanted from
this life
even so I did it's gonna be a
heartbreaking finale yeah to call myself
beloved
to feel myself beloved
on the earth she really loves him
oh
talk about give us some Romance
I'm gonna plow your ass
so you the Poetry of love making
that's where I learned Ezekiel 24 14 or
whatever you said that book got another
good book I got a poem for you I fired
Fury okay nope sorry correction I ddt'd
that dude from the top rope yeah it was
like Undertaker level
you just sprayed him with pesticide this
girl's big wrestling fans my graphic
needs what graphic doesn't need that's
none of your concern
I'm the one telling you to kill Fury oh
what damn it scrotie look I'll make it
easy for you one of the two occupants of
that lovely country manner of yours is
catching a bullet today
jeez flip coin for all I care
wow from exhaustion and defeat soon
enough we don't need to kill him man
this is sad you keep telling me what
you're not gonna do
I'm gonna show you what I am going to
ooh now you enjoy this concert
if we consider it it's just Roadie
this is who he's been all this time real
son [__] I don't need your sorrow or
your pity for anything I did of my own
free will
what is your plan for finding our people
at home because graphic has already
implemented his and it works got a
napkin in a pen we take down the
Insurgency we go to the present and we
have a big bargaining chip
just saved your planet now give me a
little something in return I can secure
an amnesty for the one million of us to
remain jeez I don't know don't you want
to live in your own skin it's very
optimistic we just keep contributing
show them our hearts they will see us
generational debate in the capsule you
were delusional and that is not who I've
become
they're gonna go right back to graphic
that's really short-lived didn't think
you'd be home until later
surprise
T sure I'll take a cup surprise
[__]
of all the Reckless things I've done in
my life
away
greatest mistake oh
shh
ignored every signal in my head heart
and body that screams
stop
I don't know that if I had a chance to
do it over again then I'd do anything
different
oh
like laying all the cards out would you
tell me the story it's going to
Tarantino movie chills her Dr Priscilla
Davis had his congenital heart defect
she was keeping it a secret
looking for someone who would slip your
defenses
ah so you playing the long game on me
even then
don't do that Nick
she gets to call him Nick I decided to
just come out and ask
I asked if she wanted to fall in love
and I told her about you
interesting make her three promises very
hurt see which I did honorable that I
would continue to be a daughter to her
parents you've also done
that I would never hurt you
oh and did you get what you wanted from
this life even so
what's about to happen I did
I think they're gonna kill her and it's
gonna be hard what did you want
to call myself beloved
ah yep
to feel
myself Beloved
the
Earth
whoa God damn
really did become a Tarantino movie
decoding the Superhuman Gene was her
book
I'm not sure if this means we should get
divorced
beautiful that was really well done
would you have loved me if I'd never
changed
if I'd been my true self
oh guess we'll never know
Secret Wars
the wars of the heart
oh they're just like us
all my fetishes are coming through on
Disney Plus
shape of water just wasn't enough oh my
God my fetishes are ruined oh
they call them War Machine
show you where the only thing Roadie has
been a scroll memory serves I [__]
canned you into Oblivion a few days ago
I didn't like the way we left things
between us I wanted to share my favorite
liquid lunch with you Papi Van Winkle
23 years of distilled Perfection I
figured we could settle our beef like
you know proper gentleman like Harry has
like a really sincere conversation with
his wife and then you see the personas
yeah yeah presentational the
interrogation tactic if you waste one
drop of this family reserve your
ancestors will reach out from the Beyond
and strangle your black ass let's drink
his for him
really a black ass he's a green ass
broken
tell you there are Scrolls inside the
U.S government
Scrolls in my security details Scrolls
in the US government that just because I
have an excellent Authority
that there is a scroll mode
very close
wow
very close close to you and I are right
now
all you got to do keep my mouth shut
about all this give me my job back you
mind if I make a counter
shouldn't have had that drink man you
see this all right
whoa that's graphic that's not me that's
a a six foot tall bald black one-eyed
extraterrestrial
foot tall one-eyed black extra restroom
my power to protect you to keep this
video and you know all the copies that I
made Under Wraps
is that audio wave yeah I was curious
it's moving still liquid location
tracker
it's not a bad idea hey clever
assuming the president bites it soon sir
Harrison Ford takes over oh hey spoilers
you have to project strength uh there's
an old linen quote Vladimir not John
when you find flesh you push when you
find steel
you stop Colonel can I ask you something
absolutely anything sir
pre-game for our bilateral with the
Russians or the half a bottle of bourbon
I'm not sure I understand the questions
sir
interesting president's got to be a
drunk to pick up on that
even though the type
oh my God
damn
no
[__] Harrison Ford's going to come
running into frame in a second any
moment
be graphic to death with ritson's body
shot yeah
this roady's not going there
good shots good shots
Chinese
it's the Russians look at them they're
clearly right
damn woof
nice this looks great yeah no it's great
sexual directed action
oh
planner to be a Killzone if we don't
save written huh
you got your pistol
oh there we go there we go
nicely done
yeah
helicopter that was sick
we're playing hot potato with the
president
cool
nervous
damn I am graphic
how many powers does he have
I wish they would all prioritize a
resting Fury
stop get this man
he's gonna let him be the one to save
the president
is everyone watching on the scroll I'm
punching this bulletproof glass I'm
gonna transform right as I pull him out
we are your friends
oh no no no no not
not my Talos
oh [__]
damn they're about fine ass girls are
come on man
let's go oh he's like sacrificing
himself on the way out
oh no
[Music]
he's with me he's with us
hey damn okay
where's Gaia so she can see this
damn that's a good makeup yeah CGI
combination
hang in there I'll be back for you
oh don't just leave him have someone
else take the president put it in my car
I got my own right
guy sympathetic for reals
trust this I don't like it
oh [__]
no I said put him down now
no no no no no no no no no no no
whoa damn it so
oh
you gotta be shitty damn
[Music]
oh you gotta be kidding me
come on we can save him oh
save him come on grab him
let's drive over there
all right
why why what do you mean who's in that
shoes yeah
oh golly don't worry guys next episode
it's gonna be night time in Towson just
gonna wake up what happened
well the only body on this freeway
all right let's talk about holy [__]
damn yeah that was a lot I was hoping in
the trailer when they showed his face
all messed up that that was just gonna
be a fake out but damn looks like they
really really got it there all right
well let's uh let's play some bets now
let's play some bets I think Talos will
not be back for five
but I think somehow
through the power
of super scrolling Shenanigans
they might be able to bring him back for
episode I think in the final episode
we'll come back I feel like they're
gonna make us think he's dead for a
whole one a whole yeah yeah yeah let's
adjust it Jesus koi how many times
there it is uh do you think he's dead
dead I'm gonna double down like I did
with Amelia Clarke I love you Ben
Mendelson but you did I feel like he's
going or or
he's actually going they will bring him
back but he's going to let everyone
think he's still dead that way his dad
Warren Samaritan yeah exactly
yeah yeah
I'm going that's where I'm going with my
theory on that sure but um if he
actually is dead that's a really solid
sacrifice and it went down that whole
path saving the president in public if
given up your identity doing it like the
very thing you said to your daughter you
do being a man of your word now we know
though that Harrison Ford is going to be
they've already confirmed it that he
will be president in Captain America new
world order do you think he might undo
whatever happens here for the Scrolls
maybe Dermot Mulroney is able to do oh
who knows if Dormont even makes it what
if the sacrifice was in vain care about
what happened in this episode now I'm
only thinking about the future seven
movies yeah
either president is gonna you know try
and do some scroll-based uh you know
policy pumping is there an ending you
can explain or Easter eggs you can point
out or or maybe did he know maybe he'll
just get uh his term and we'll just end
yeah
the new president by way of Elections
yeah oh man that was a heavy episode man
I'm like wiped yeah that was really
emotional I was very invested in the
emotionality of the first half and then
the action of the second half and then
all of a sudden there was an emotional
action
there was there was I thought the the
action was well done it was beautifully
there's not a lot of action in this show
and so when it was happening I was like
all right this is good this is like
actually Ali slam got to Showcase some
of his you know action prowess and I
love a good that I feel like that's the
new thing now has a lot of good mounted
locked off shots nice mounted uh POV
angles other items in motion
yeah I really like the way I looked
though I also really like that they set
up to have it like off to the side so
they could really get good coverage of
the fight like they had the presidential
you know cavalcade go over here and then
you could really shoot the fight and do
real practical explosions like some of
that was CJ but they actually blew some
stuff up they did oh Easter egg Easter
egg keyword thank God for getting this
out of the way
grew tanned root hand yeah yep he's got
Groot abilities that he just like
selfishly take them all on or did he
like evenly distribute this amongst all
the other you know intercourages
part of me does Wonder here's my theory
to get that uh that click word uh I
think that he will have taken so many
treatments of the super scroll juice
whatever it is that he will gain all
these Powers but they will be too much
for his body to yeah
I am the Mandarin yes exactly I think he
explodes like the end of blade or he
just pumps all that blood
of things oh man uh I I really was
impressed with everyone's acting this
considering they had to do a lot in 30
some minutes in this episode and like
that means every scene had to be like
that was a really good fake out with the
whole thing with the wife oh man the
Cutaway they shut the house yeah yeah
because it seemed like they were said I
was thinking okay it's going to be like
heartbreaking by the by the end of the
series right and then if they killed her
off if they if it killed off part of me
was gonna be like man this is really sad
the other part of me was I wish we got
to spend a little bit more time getting
invested in their you know actual
relationship and then they did both this
episode because they were kind of blue
valentining it you know where they would
cut to like they're in love in the
flashback it's gone horribly it's
horrible and depressing you know uh and
they're singing with a banjo Let It Ride
Gosling rest yeah yes uh but oh dude
someone put I think on one of our live
streams they pointed out that the person
who plays his wife is actually the one
who plays this is small the places is
Samuel Jackson's mom from the glass
definitely expanded
I was like it's his mom what is
happening
John it's not
but the emotion that she brings uh
because you could feel that conflict
that she's having the whole time because
I wasn't as exactly 100 on board because
they they didn't confirm what her plan
was in the last episode or what she was
being instructed to do right by Roadie
to kill Nick I was like wow that's a
reveal that you're just dropping on me
at the beginning of this episode and
then when she's having that
confrontation at the table that had so
much sorrow and I loved I loved the way
how uh Samuel Jackson played that whole
moment too because uh like we pointed
out he was so like dejected and it was
another one of those speeches of like
yeah you know this was like a big
mistake but I also don't regret any of
it yeah so the way they did lead up to
them ultimately pulling the trigger on
each other and the way they've reacted
to after the triggers were pulled that's
the relationship yeah yeah that's the
good Blue Valentine like they're back in
the happy for this moment and it's
because they can laugh about that and
accept these kind of weird
idiosyncrasies about each other and
stuff strange perspectives about life
like this is just a weird lifestyle we
live you know what you think about our
backstory John what do you think about
Priscilla's backstory I thought that was
very interesting and touching good
abductions out there yeah no it seemed
like a really beautiful and I liked I I
love when you get a story told in
monologue that never breaks from just
the actor delivering the monologue and
you can see it in your head and uh and I
thought that was an example this this
was I thought like an overall really
strong episode and especially for things
like that and I thought that yeah what
her story was because you sit here and
wonder you're like yeah they have to
take on people's personae and these are
good skulls how do they do that and I
really like the idea of like please live
my life like I love the idea of her
saying like do you want to fall in love
like that's so painful sure like do you
want this Visage to know love because
you're dying Imma Be You Like that's
just so heavy yeah absolutely beautiful
monologue and it's like yeah it's like
it it is a little odd and twisted but in
a way that ultimately turns out quite
beautiful and I think that that showing
her true compassion giving like a kind
of nice window into who she actually is
because between her and Nick like
there's a lot of these Espionage games
and stuff
um but yeah I thought that was
wonderfully humanizing and that combined
with how that scene ultimately played
out yeah made that a perfect moment
whereas again if I if if she was about
to die I feel like I would have kind of
felt undercut yeah yeah exactly yeah and
now to uh no smooth transition here but
with Roadie yes Don Cheadle really gets
to Showcase his acting caliber here
because
the the you have the one scene with him
in episode two uh where he fires Nick
right and now that it's revealed that uh
he was a scroll by the way he makes a
hot ass girl I mean you were getting the
shower
[Music]
[Laughter]
let me find my words
um oh yes
normally when you when they do like are
we a villain reveal and then this actor
shows up he's like hang on now I'm now
I'm playing into the fact that I'm
really a scroll right it didn't do that
it still felt like the same performance
carrying over from episode two and in
episode two it was only supposed to semi
make you question episode two wasn't
enough to make me go he's definitely a
scroll right you know it's enough to
still make me go that could still just
be Roadie's principles speaking here and
and roady's mentality and perspective on
the whole situation speaking on this
matter where's Nick right no it makes
really solid writing and I like how this
still feels like the same performance
there even though now they've let the
audience know that he is a scroll and he
only like I love the cat and mouse game
of that conversation because you know
Nick's obviously taunting him so much
and he start you could tell in Don
cheadle's um performance the way he's
reacting to him that does Nick know him
actually yeah you know how much is
debating me or is this just being him
being him yeah I I really enjoy that we
don't know you asked her in the episode
like when he took over I really love
that like we don't know yet like I love
that there's a mystery but there's still
more mystery like we've solved some of
it and we don't know and it's I'm really
curious that they've like picked someone
that has been recast you know it's it's
interesting that Terrence Howard's one
of the only Marvel characters that's
like a new face and he's a skrull and
he's got a movie coming out so there's a
lot might have been Avengers end game
that's my prediction he wanted to kill
Hitler and he went back Hitler was a
scroll that would explain a lot yeah
baby Thanos that's what it was skriller
I mean Deadpool went back to go kill
little baby Hitler and then he's got a
movie coming out so maybe don't matter
maybe yeah coming soon Taco it he's
gonna play babies
[Laughter]
take away these Google Hitler this is
called Joe rabbit it's a prequel oh God
uh it's late
extremist group Powers oh guy is back
yay all right congratulations hey you're
gonna get some true meat to that
performance and then but then they kill
her dad you get like five seconds on the
bench with her and they're like man it's
like they cast Emilia Clark and whenever
I feel like we're we're finally about to
get some real mealia Clark scenes come
on come on we just don't get eyes are so
big and full of depth let us do
something well like I want to like live
with her for a bit well that's what I
think
um you know uh that that's why Talus
being fridged you know am I use I'm
using the term properly only a woman can
be fridge no no yeah yeah Telus is
fridge yeah it serves the purpose
yeah Nick Fury
and then now we'll get some time with
Gaia as as she's you know that graphic
guy is such an [__] such a dick such
a dick and now he's got powers
so a lot of this at the beginning of
this episode uh you know did speak
towards uh Nick Fury's righteousness
side but also you know part of his
stubborn qualities do you think he made
the right decision in just leaving Talos
at the end John you go first you take
the decision I think you may have to be
careful you're white because come come
across gracious you should have
absolutely just run directly to tell us
the side and firemen lifted him and then
pulled the car by hand off the freeway
uh correct answer I think he made the
the decision for the Optics as you would
say of the situation he made the
decision that he had to make
uh if it was me out of trying to go back
for Telos but he's kind of freaking
saved the president like I don't know
too many things could go wrong so I get
why it happened personally I uh I feel
like he is you know in and out of
government favor and also been on the
run and kind of a fugitive and half the
government might be his girls because
Roadie is saving their president's a
good step in the chess game but their
friendship was so strong and they'd
known each other so many years I wish he
could have tried I would have tried well
that's where my the knits of my pick
come in because Nick Fury
my friends don't call me Nick they call
me don't worry about it a thousand
little details
get anything done he is so Fury
half of these proposition files are just
minutia man come up with a plan uh no
this was an episode that for all of us
we have struck the right tone for this
episode
the knits of my picks for this episode
this was one of those ones where like
all the great things about it kind of
brought into relief what I'm worried
about which is during this one I was
like man if this was like an Andor 12
episodes or something like we could
really cook some of this stuff and I
feel like especially with some aspects
of the emotional story because we only
really have big
visual on the scroll conflict in Captain
Marvel so this even though it's all
running alongside the universe and the
MCU and they're they're hopping around
in different movies you know timelines
and whatnot it still feels like this
story has really kind of only been
happening through Captain Marvel to this
so it feels still kind of contained to
me and I you know it's supposed to be
like damn this big steak is affecting
like everything we know about how the
world works right now okay I agree
because I think that a lot of the scenes
when it's just like scene work the best
thing the show has gone for it is like
when they just have like two actors
talking to each other love it they're
just great scenes
and then you kind of feel like but the
overall story would just feel that much
more exponential if they had more of a
run time with these last couple episodes
too
put a little bit more juice in there so
that one's left and then it's starting
to feel like oh it's not exactly rushed
but a little too short yeah like
somewhere there well I'm a little
worried about how it wraps up because
the first two episodes were so long and
then the next one last one was like it
was a little shorter than the last house
and this did a kind of two sides of the
coin for me because during the scene
with Priscilla I was like okay they
might lose me oh no wait this is the
perfect choice for what we've gotten to
experience for this show and then with
talo so Talos whatever I I was sitting
there going man I would feel this a lot
harder if we had really like I love one
more man I love their relationship I
love a lot of that stuff but there's not
quite enough in that Foundation to make
me like choke up or something like that
when they threaten us with this because
they also had him in a lot of other
episodes get his like oh awesome moment
in this episode he like sat in the bench
and like the way he saved was great but
like he had that underwhelming big plan
and I was like okay now he's dead you're
a big player so I would have loved one
more Scene could have had a better build
up to that moment yeah like overall
through it it's still like again it's
like isolated scenes but if there was
like other thing other scenes in between
to just add on to it then it's called
what's called fleshing it out right
um but yeah uh overall I still love the
show I still think there's some of the
best scene work in all the MCU it's like
right here yeah uh so yeah surprises
yeah man I still really like the episode
let's see if uh Disney plus can uh stick
the landing and I can't wait to see all
the actors promote this come the finale
um yeah buddy you know when tomorrow
goes well and everything goes back to
normal it's coming tomorrow what's
happening all right guys well leave your
nitpicks down below knit Fury yeah and
it's Fury
cadent Nick Fury yeah leave it down
below uh subscribe thank you to bird
dogs for um you know not dogging on my
my legs and uh playing Guy Gardner
cool and
um
of the day shout out
Michael B on the media no it's just
Michael B I actually know his last name
I should by this point I know it oh it's
right there no it's not is this last
name
Michael B movie Omni media is his
YouTube channel I like this guy here's
the thing is we're shooting this
midnight and uh shooting and editing you
know we're doing our thing he is three
hours ahead and he is doing the exact
same thing so he's starting as a 3am so
loser suffer sucker
your Sleepless Sunrise is coming inside
that that shows his hard work and
dedication so if you haven't checked out
his YouTube Channel please go ahead and
do that show him some love let him know
real rejects sent you especially if
you're coming to this portion of the
video this is late it was like an hour
before in our video uh that means you're
a loyal follower so please go ahead show
him some support because he absolutely
deserves it he's even done some
reactions here with me so guys thank you
Omni for being here and uh thank you all
for being here I'll talk to you all soon
ASAP reject Nation